- Elon Musk is going to trial over Twitter
and fast, really fast.
Twitter wanted to go to trial in September
as in just a few days away.
But the chancellor, AKA the
judge, sided with Twitter
and set the trial for October
as in, also not very far away.
Elon Musk wanted to set the
trial for February, 2023,
which was very close to the expiration
of the financing obligations
and that might have been a
bid to blow up the whole deal.
If you don't have financing,
maybe you can't go forward with it.
And Musk wanted extra time
for extensive discovery
related to his too many
bots on Twitter theory
but that's not really relevant
to whether this particular
deal needs to close.
So this is generally
bad news for Elon Musk
and good news for Twitter.
This is fast.
And as I've said before,
don't mess around with the
Delaware Chancery courts
or you might find out,
just like Elon Musk did.